per questo fare perfetto che aveva
capito you win
ma come come unito allo ragazzi prima di
partire una considerazione slither
dunque che cazzo vuol dire slither
dunque spiega mi mandava seriamente
ragazze belle tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo video sono vari j
ed oggi siamo su twitter dunque
c'è un bellissimo livello di happy meals
complimenti zio tra world facciamo
questa quadra che ha meno bello siam
passati da un livello di merda un
livello decente subito più che non è
morto che forse non è così bello story
della micro e devo ma era torna merda
aspettai posto ancora non c'e look
perfetto è bene complimenti luke sei
stato nuovo definitivo per questo
livello trono allora mondo disegnato che
tanto è disegnato molto meglio di come
so disegnare ero ok è morto perfetto
oddio mai aveva il prefetto
thanks for plaining mica bravissimo zio
edy veramente i disegnini addio ai anche
una calligrafia carina ragazzi voi
dovreste vedere come scrivo io
sant'egidio c'è ancora la calligrafia di
uno ed elementari get revenge e prendi
la tua vendetta lancia le vittime aiuta
a ha voluto lanciare problemi non si è
mai troppo cattivi in questa vita vero
io pensavo molto peggio
pertanto ritengo con una mano sola che
il cazzo sono maciste avevi intenzione
di farti mia moglie o cose davo ragazzi
ancora lei ha scoraggiato mano con un po
scoraggiare una bambina le bambine non
scoraggia set altro non è morta non si è
morta ragazzi possono giocare più epico
in selezionati veramente minimi mi
inquieta sto gioco più ha davanti più
inquieta cesto problema di fondo
possible level d'aprica tofani che ben
il nome zio complimenti grazie prica
toni per aver fatto questo livello
bruxelles ormai facciamo lo facciamo lì
tutti in fila alla gara perché tanto e
12 porcate amica che morte strana
passate di sottotipo cosa stai facendo
non fatevi riprovare vi prego beh bravo
michette stata fortissima che ho dato e
non ci arriva porca miglior tale pro
quasi è l'idea era buona lega almeno
l'idea passa teme l'arresto ha fatto un
po cagare prove no vabbè no vabbè cosa
sto facendo santo iddio sicuramente
chiudevo cui chiude voli il video
ragazzi
[Musica]
333 che è la metà di 666 non c'entra un
cazzo professor figo signor la oddio non
bisogna tentare la fortuna faccio
veramente cagare so però convinto di
vincere io sennò va beh ma come cazzo si
fa si sta muovendo paragrafo se forse ci
arriva forse perché sistemone ma
veramente va bene coloro switch ragazzi
sarà un'avventura fantasmagorica livello
1 se diventa due non ho capito giuro a
dovevo entrare dentro ho capito quindi
io scelgo il colore e poi entro dentro a
ben giallo quindi fosse data l'attuale
condizione di questa ruota rappresenta
più o meno lo stato emotivo di un
ragazzo che soffre differenze devo
capire solo come veramente non so come
hai fatto un genio un genio
allora già le mie amiche a questo è
difficile non darebbe qualcuno che culo
ce l'ho fatta sul serio dai vai perfetto
non ci credo mai veramente ma io non ho
capito ma sa roba qua è un gioco è
un'applicazione per iphone che cos'è sta
roba sembra conosciuto sto gioco me non
l'ho mai fatto in vita mia quindi cos'è
grazie veniamo ti muoia il criceto di
infarto altro questi dovrebbero essere
più semplici non triangoli quadrati
infatti una cagata infatti è una mezza
cagata se non ci fosse sempre alla ruota
in friends on
ci ho provato e vabbè ma non posso fin
davanti ciao rotas minchia zio cosa vuoi
che faccia avrà mai capito
ti odio che prendessero a schiaffi e
veramente cosa è successo
sono tornato indietro non volevo giuro è
il mio cervello che automaticamente
vuole che io mi allontani da happy ways
perché non ne può più giustamente torino
ho adocchiato un livello bello tipo
questo ciao bomba un bellissimo diverso
dai forza fratello a forza fa il
fratello che ce la faccia
bravissimo però dovresti parlare con un
po più sguardo e fight django santo
iddio no va bene ci mancava solo di
sfidare tarda notte merde ma dai
sono incapaci sono il campo e va bene
quanto forte ragazzi non ci riesco
chi è possibile e va a qualcuno non
risco neanche a bloccarlo l'uragano non
è possibile ma non c'è verso re va bene
o quanto può essere difficile ho mica
quanto di morire allora come adesso mi
acclama adesso solo per convinto bravo
zio in questa posizione ti voglio degli
impossible soprano eva per quei tavoli
come o fuso tutti gli arpioni possibili
immaginabili della vita col jump ma ho
sbagliato ma è con tubo jump questo fare
perfetto credo di aver capito you win
ma come come ho visto cosa ha fatto 9
non ci credo sono caduto sopra non è
possibile non ci voglio credere mai nave
dopo questo sono gasatissimo certo
facendo bossi col sono proprio convinto
ma non escono anche a parare il cac ha
preso cazzo cazzo cazzo
l'ho preso
passa la mano come si fa a fare simposi
lo spiegate melo ma ok ma infratel e va
rispettata e tira non ci credo non ci
credo sono morto così sono morte
veramente così tira maledizione mica
quanto geniale sto in prossimo non ci
voglio credere mai magari difficilissimo
[Musica]
mi sa che hai sbagliato direzione credo
è mai vecchia o dai maledizione perfetto
ho messo una vita però ce l'ho fatto
incredibile monster jam extreme la guido
io la guido io la guido io e spacchiamo
tutto spaccavo non dubai signor nitro ma
che nitro io ascolto salma over space to
start va bene potete levare questi
rumori di sottofondo che mi fanno salire
il nazismo
no vabbè reagan
basta casinò c'è l'offerta non ci sono
mai 67 ore italiani in poi talian c'è un
impossible italiano due tra l'altro da
alessandro m 19 va bene walker ed
attento alla testa o più light è già
detto è andata è stata in talpe nemmeno
l'ho staccato madonna che sento bello
stavo scherzando bravissimo bravissimo
scarsissimo levissima purissimo
altissima e [ __ ] dica quanto è
difficile l'inizio del cascato tutto
microfono tutto però ce l'ho fatta dai
ragazzi io direi che posso fare
obiettivo che casino questo è successo
scassato micro bene cerchiamo di avere
le relazioni più contenuta la prossima
volta scusate sono impazzito
stavo pensando di fare uno speciale con
i miei livelli con l'approccio del
prossimo episodio non lo so però nel
caso se mi fate tanti livelli nel
prossimo episodio vedrò di farlo quindi
fatemi sapere ragazzi e cromie episodio
ragazzi spero che vide vi sia piaciuto
spero che microfono si sa bene perché
dio mio cavallo che tu se vi è piaciuta
sarà un commento è un mi piace anche a
parlare di facebook e come la
descrizione ci vediamo al prossimo vito
e ragazzi